welcome to this video which is ICC five
minutes chest I'm playing hon 413
wherever that is um let's see to
rearrange stuff you on my desk I'm
playing a pretty solid opening here the
Queens gambit declined with black rook
see one huh can you do hmm if I go here
can you use that yeah maybe you can take
on d5 now but it shouldn't be that big a
deal III I know I can go see 5 this is a
very solid line where black has good
equalizing chances but it's not
particularly exciting admittedly let's
see what we get here and always like to
trade this night the sometimes give
black gets black the opportunity to play
a quickie Bishop f6 of course in cases
where the night is not just hanging him
okay here he has to take care of Queen
a5 check usually white it goes a three
yep and now i'm going for this and black
it sir as mentioned now in a very solid
situation no Bishop d3 this is a bit
uncommon because you you normally want
to go Bishop b5 to prevent Bishop f6
there it's no big deal but what is he
doing now are there with the b2 pond you
cannot go before yeah this you can do
but I don't know is it is it that great
I can take or queen queen bee 6
immediately yeah let's do that
immediately
if he goes before you shouldn't forget
that white is not very well developed so
deform yeah i mean before i have d 4 94
94 Bishop g4 night be three wins an
exchange probably yeah there are already
some tricks going on okay but yeah I can
take f3e right take a three take f6 I
cheeky to what is the big deal there I
don't get it am I not just a piece of
why am I not a piece up here ok I think
I am
yeah so much for playing a super solid
opening you have peace up after move 16
okay my king is a bit shaky but it's
really not not that much it's just one
check and I go nite g7 being safe white
resigns yeah it should be five of course
was a blunder but it already was at
least it looked to me a little bit
uncomfortable this is certainly or
normal until white dude this this
normally after which bishop f6 should
equalize for black ultimately but
nothing special going on they have quite
often you get a situation where black
gets in d4 and the whole position kind
of evaporates into nothing something
something like this as I said it's super
solid but also a little bit boring and
he went here and now after this I
already found rather comfortable a bit
b2 is sorry I didn't want to do this b2
is hanging and the normal move before
runs into this and hmm yeah and
something like this yeah I have the
check I'm not taking and course this is
blundering the bishop as i can check
here after 92 something like this you
you feel that there is this this
development problem and we went here
Queen B 6 yeah nobody should be five
just blunders the house so he has to do
something else the engine children
suggests 95b should be five bishop
five takes takes snow f6 mac and dee for
the slide edge for black yeah definitely
I mean I can take on e3 next and this
should be a slight advantage I've got
the somewhat better pawn structure it's
nothing nothing that great but certainly
comfortable yeah that was just just a
piece for no compensation at all okay
well thanks for watching